so we were talking about like what we
miss about certain eras of television
the other day and we were talking about
Carson of course Johnny and we were
saying hmm all the people that crossed
his path
all the people who he'd goof with on
ston stage and then I didn't realized
that he discovered you he did I've read
in the trades I was living in Sausalito
they were looking for a girl a
small-town girl who had no idea what she
looked like and didn't know who she was
and I thought that's me and I got
together the $25.00 flew to Los Angeles
to NBC Burbank ignorance is you know is
great because I didn't know there's a
way to do this with agents and appoint
all three of 21 1990 I walk in I Drive
up I was in love with Alan Hamels so I
had him picked me up and I said I have
an interview at NBC he didn't ask and he
just knew he could sleep with me and I
come up to NBC and why are you here I'm
here for the Dom DeLuise show I'll go
over there and park over there so I read
and they said oh very nice we're giving
you a call back I said great so I go out
to the receptionist I have a call back
and she said that's good for you and I
said what is that she said they're gonna
call you back yeah where do I go and now
I'm her problem she's irritated cuz well
I don't know go wait in the commissary I
guess words that changed my life I'm
sitting there all by myself like this
good Catholic schoolgirl with my hands
crossed my and we all I can always tell
they went to Catholic school by this
look at this threesome here and I'm
sitting there and I see over there oh my
god that's Johnny Carson oh my god
that's Johnny Carson's coming he's
walking over towards me oh he's walking
towards me and he says hey little lady
what are you doing here and I said I
have a callback because now I have lingo
right
[Laughter]
so this is Wednesday I handed in my only
thing I had was my book of poetry in one
credit report three poetry 1973 my book
on the back I had my one credit that I
was the mysterious blonde in the
Thunderbird
so it's Wednesday and Friday night I
made my debut on television charged
address I couldn't afford $76 which
seems like so much money at the time and
I thought oh my god he loved my poetry
and I hear Johnny Carson say we've all
been wondering who the mysterious blonde
and the Thunderbird is an American
Graffiti and I'm thinking you were
because I hadn't seen the movie yes and
the curtain opened and he just loved me
because I was so innocent innocent yeah
every month for years and my book of
poetry became the number one
best-selling book of poetry alumni Rod
McKuen Freddy Silverman over at ABC he
sees you yeah they're casting the show
Three's Company
but he's already cast to actresses as
Chrissy snow you're right and what
happened the didn't test well and he
said in the meeting Laura goes I got the
girl I see her on The Tonight Show all
the time like right place right time I
don't know the stars lined up for me so
what an interesting ride it's been well
and then the show is such a huge success
you're you're the it girl you're the
cover girl in the 70s number-one show
yeah number-one show in the country very
racy
now people sell this very racy like my
parents would let me watch the Three's
Company my parents do
so so but compared to today
oh and television today this is positive
you were positively prudish back in that
day in fact Chrissy snow was kissed once
her first kiss was in those six years
but her whole thing was moral outrage
and everything like that you know things
you shouldn't do yeah I mean it's like
it's just wild because it was it was you
you if you're a certain age you were not
supposed to watch that show those rules
are out the window right so what is your
thought today about the quality of
entertainment we kind of joked that
there's a lot of you know a lot of
repetition they're doing you know
everything is being done over Jurassic
Park again doing Willy Wonka again until
the Three's Company reboot I have an
idea oh I'm so sorry John is gone
wouldn't that would be a wonder he was
magic he was absolutely you guys made up
after the month months before he died he
never went after I was fired the the it
became you're either with us and against
her or with her and against us so more
money to be paid with commensurate with
what the men were being paid the men
were being paid 10 and 15 times more
than me and I'm on the number-one show
with the highest demographics of all
women in primetime at that time and so I
still feel right that I were asking for
it but he never talked to me again none
of it none of the cast or crew ever they
thought you reckon the show and I think
that that was what they were fed that
she's trying to ruin our show and a
month before John died I'm at the beauty
salon and I'm having my hair shampooed
and you have a phone call so thank you
can you take a message it's John Ritter
hmm go over and I pick up the phone and
he says look babe I forgive you which
took me a moment it took me a moment and
I thought put on your big-girl pants who
nice - thanks I've had a lot of therapy
and he wanted me to appear in a dream
sequence on the show he was doing you
want to Joyce and I to appear in a
nightmare he's having I would I said you
know there's kind of a hunger for us to
reunite I don't think this is what it'd
have happened if he had lived you think
yes so that's what we decided to look
for a project together and then a month
a month later he dies what about the
meat - movement good thing a little too
political is it is everyone afraid to
like hug each other now I mean what's
going on why this probably won't be real
popular but I think that women I totally
understand the Weinstein and Bill Cosby
and that's like of course but you know
like Morgan Freeman's a big flirt hey I
know him really well and he sees you and
he'll like your dress and he'll like
your hair and he'll like you like a lot
of things and I hope the dance doesn't
stop the it's it's it's seduction it's
flirting all those things are really fun
so I hope there's a way we can find a
nice medium with that and you're
incredibly successful businesswoman
you've recreated yourself in so many
different ways it's how do you know when
I opened my Broadway one-woman show I
said I'm Asha Moo and I said you know
what if shmoo is I said my brother got
one for Christmas one year it's a
life-size punching bag that has a clown
face you punch it it bounces back you
punch it bouncing it doesn't matter how
many times you punch it it always
bounces back and I sort of lived my life
like a smooth so anytime there's
anything negative I now I'm old enough
to say where's the lesson what am I
supposed to learn what am i teaching
myself using negatives at like judo
using jujitsu exactly and my husband I
have this great partnership and he does
what he does and I do it I do secret to
a 40-year marriage
happy 14050 about fifty years together
we complement each other a lot in
mean--it and gratitude I wake up
honestly every morning and I talked
about how grateful I am for the life
that I have and him and love and family
and all that fantastic both for both of
us we were just such huge fans here
personally and professionally thank you
so much for being with us thank you a
mount of time today we really appreciate